Hoy voy a hablarles acerca de
convertir el miedo en esperanza
Cuando vamos con el especialista actualmente,
cuando llegamos al consultorio y entramos,
hay palabras que no queremos escuchar.
Hay palabras a las que tenemos genuino temor.
Diabetes, cancer, Parkinson, Alzheimer,
falla cardiaca, falla pulmonar.
Cosas que sabemos son enfermedades que debilitan,
de las cuales relativamente poco puede hacerse.
Y lo que quiero establecer el día de hoy es
una manera diferente de cómo tratar estas enfermedades debilitantes,
por qué es importante.
Por qué sin esto, quizá nuestro sistema de salud se desmorone,
si es que piensan que ésto aún no ha ocurrido.
Y dónde nos encontramos hoy, clínicamente hablando, y dónde podríamos encontrarnos mañana,
y cuáles son algunos de los obstáculos.
Haremos todo esto en 18 minutos, lo prometo.
Quiero comenzar con esta diapositiva
por que ésta narra la historia de cómo la revista "Science" ilustra el concepto.
Esta es una edición de 2002
en donde publicaron diversos artículos sobre el humano biónico
Básicamente se trató de una edición de medicina regenerativa.
La medicina regenerativa es un concepto extraordinariamente sencillo
que todos pueden entender.
Se trata simplemente de acelerar el ritmo al cual el cuerpo se cura a si mismo
a una escala de tiempo clínicamente relevante.
Nosotros sabemos cómo hacer esto en varias de las maneras indicadas ahí.
Sabemos que nos dañamos un hueso,éste se puede reemplazar por uno artificial.
Y esta es la idea que la revista "Science" usó en su portada.
Esto es totalmente opuesto a la medicina regenerativa.
Esto no es medicina regenerativa.
Medicina regenerativa es lo que publicó "Business Week"
cuando escribieron una historia al respecto no hace mucho.
La idea es que, en lugar de imaginarse como disminuir los síntomas
con dispositivos, medicinas y similares --
y retomaré este tema varias veces más --
en lugar de hacer eso, regeneraremos las funciones perdidas del cuerpo
mediante la regeneración del funcionamiento de organos y tejido dañado.
Para que al final del tratamiento,
usted sea el mismo de como estaba al inicio del tratamiento.
Muy pocas buenas ideas -- si están de acuerdo que ésta es una buena idea --
muy pocas ideas son de verdad novedosas.
Y esta no es la excepción.
Si revisan la historia,
Charles Lindbergh -- quien es mejor conocido por volar aeroplanos--
fue en realidad de las primeras personas,
junto con Alexis Carrel, uno de los ganadores Nobel desde Rockefeller,
en comenzar a pensar ¿se pueden cultivar órganos?
Ellos publicaron este libro en 1937,
donde ellos comenzaron a pensar,
¿qué podría hacerse en bio-reactores para crecer órganos completos?
Hemos logrado mucho desde entonces.
Voy a compartir con ustedes algo del emocionante trabajo que se está realizando
Pero antes, quisiera yo
compartirles mi depresión respecto al sistema de salud
y la necesidad de esto con ustedes.
Varias de las charlas de ayer se refirieron a
la mejora de la calidad de vida y reducir la pobreza.
Y en escencia incrementar la esperanza de vida en todo el mundo.
Uno de los retos es que mientras más ricos seamos más viviremos.
Y mientras más vivamos, más caro será
cuidar de nuestras enfermedades mientras envejecemos.
Esto es simplemente el bienestar de un país
contra el porcentaje de población que tiene más de 65 años
Y pueden ver que mientras más rico es un pais,
tendrá más personas de mayor edad en él.
¿Por qué es esto relevante?
¿Y por qué esto es un reto particularmente dramático actualmente?
Si la edad promedio de su poblacion es de 30 años,
entonces el tipo de enfermedad promedio que se tratará
probablemente sea un talón fracturado de vez en cuando,
quizá un poco de asma.
Si la edad promedio de la población en su país es de 45 a 55 años,
entonces la persona promedio enfrentará diabetes,
pre diabetes, falla cardiaca, enfermedad de la arteria coronaria.
Enfermedades que son inherentemente más dificiles de tratar,
y mucho más caras de tratar.
Solo observen las estadísticas en Estados Unidos.
Esto es de Estados Unidos de América.
En 1930 habían 41 trabajadores por retirado.
41 personas que básicamente no estaban enfermas en realidad,
pagando por un retirado que experimentaba una enfermedad debilitante.
En 2010, dos trabajadores por retirado en EUA.
Y eso coincide en todos los países industrializados y ricos en el mundo.
¿Cómo puede mantenerse el tratamiento de pacientes,
cuando la realidad de envecejer se ve así?
Esto es edad contra el costo de la salud.
Y pueden ver que justo alrededor de los 45, 40 a 45 años,
hay un incremento súbito en el costo de la salud.
Es muy interesante --si se hacen los estudios correctos,
pueden ver cuánto gastan ustedes, como individuos, en su propia salud,
representado a lo largo de su vida.
Y alrededor de siete años antes de morir, hay un pico.
Y ustedes pueden --
(risas)
--no entraremos en esto.
Hay pocas cosas, muy pocas cosas que pueden hacer
para cambiar la forma en que pueden tratar este tipo de enfermedades
y experimentar lo que yo llamo una vejez sana.
Yo sugiero que hay cuatro cosas.
Y ninguna de estas incluye un sistema de seguros o sistema legal.
Lo que hacen esas cosas es cambiar al que paga.
Estas no cambian el costo actual del tratamiento.
Una cosa que pueden hacer es no tratarse. Pueden racionar los cuidados.
Pero no hablaremos de ello. Es muy deprimente.
Pueden prevenir.
Obviamente bastante dinero debería invertirse en la prevención.
Pero quizá lo más interesante, para mi, y más importante,
es la idea de diagnosticar una enfermedad más temprano en su progresión,
y entonces tratar la enfermedad para curarla
en lugar de tratar un síntoma.
Piensen en esto en términos de la diabetes, por ejemplo.
Actualmente, con la diabetes ¿qué hacemos?
Diagnosticamos la enfermedad eventualmente, una vez que muestra síntomas,
y entonces tratamos los síntomas por 10, 20, 30, 40 años.
Y nos va bien. La Insulina es una buena terapia.
Pero eventualmente dejará de funcionar,
y la diabetes nos lleva a un conjunto predecible de enfermedades debilitantes.
¿Por qué no inyectar el páncreas con algo
para regenerar el páncreas al inicio de la enfermedad,
quizás incluso antes de que muestre síntomas?
Y puede que sea un poco caro en el momento en que lo hagamos,
pero si funciona, podríamos entonces hacer algo diferente.
Este video, pienso, explica el concepto al que me refiero, de manera dramática.
Este es un tritón regenerando su extremidad.
Si un tritón puede hacer esto ¿por qué nosotros no?
Les mostraré algunas características importantes
sobre la regeneración de actividades en un momento.
Pero de lo que hablamos acerca de la medicina regenerativa
es hacer esto en cada sistema de órganos del cuerpo,
para los tejidos y para los órganos.
La realidad actual es que si nos enfermamos,
el mensaje es que trataremos los síntomas,
y usted deberá ajustarse a un nuevo estilo de vida.
Les plantearé que para mañana --
y podemos debatir cuando será mañana--
pero se vislumbra en el futuro --
podremos hablar de rehabilitación regenerativa.
Aquí se muestra una prótesis de extremidad
similar a la que usa el soldado
que regresó de Iraq
hay 370 soldados que regresaron de Iraq y que perdieron extremidades.
Imaginen que en lugar de esto, ellos pudieran
realizar la regeneración de dicha extremidad.
Es un concepto radical.
Les mostraré donde nos encontramos actualmente trabajando en ese concepto.
Pero es aplicable, de nuevo, a todo el sistema de órganos.
¿Cómo podemos hacer eso?
La forma de hacerlo es desarrollar una conversación con el cuerpo.
Necesitamos aprender el lenguaje del cuerpo.
Y cambiar a los procesos que conocimos cuando éramos fetos.
Un feto de mamífero, si pierde un miembro durante el primer trimestre del embarazo,
regenerará ese miembro.
Entonces su ADN tiene la capacidad de hacer este tipo de mecanismos de sanación.
Es un proceso natural,
pero se pierde cuando crecemos.
En un niño, antes de que cumpla seis meses,
Si pierden la punta del dedo en un accidente,
les crecerá de nuevo la punta del dedo.
Para cuando tienen cinco años ya no podrá hacer eso.
Para poder conversar con el cuerpo,
necesitamos hablar su lenguaje.
Y existen ciertas herramientas que nos permiten hacer eso hoy en día.
Les daré un ejemplo de tres de estas herramientas
para conversar con el cuerpo.
La primera es terapia celular.
Claramente, nos curamos en un proceso natural,
usando células para hacer el trabajo.
Por lo tanto, si encontramos las células adecuadas
e implantarlas en el cuerpo, estas podrían curarnos.
Segundo, usar materiales.
Vimos ayer la importancia de nuevos materiales.
Si podemos inventar materiales, diseñarlos,
o extraerlos de un ambiente natural,
entonces podríamos usar ese material para que el cuerpo se cure a sí mismo.
Y finalmente, podríamos usar dispositivos inteligentes
que quitarán carga de trabajo al cuerpo y le permitirán curarse.
Les mostraré un ejemplo de cada uno de estos,
y comenzaré con materiales.
Steve Badylak --que está en la Universidad de Pittsburgh --
hace una década tuvo una idea admirable.
Esa idea fue que el intestino delgado de un cerdo,
si se le quitan todas las células,
haciéndolo de manera que le permita permanecer biológicamente activo,
podría contener todos los factores y señales necesarios
para indicarle al cuerpo que se sane a sí mismo.
Y el se hizo una pregunta muy importante.
Él pregunto,
Si tomo ese material, que es un material natural
que normalmente induce la sanación del intestino delgado,
y lo coloco en el cuerpo de otra persona,
¿ocasionará una respuesta específica del tejido,
o desarrollará un intestino delgado si yo tratara de hacer una nueva oreja?
No les contaría esta historia si no fuera necesario.
La imagen que voy a mostrarles --
(risas)
-- es una imagen necesaria.
Sin embargo, para aquellos que son más impresionables --
aun cuando se resistan a admitirlo frente a sus amigos --
las luces están apagadas. Es buen momento para que vean sus pies,
revisen sus agendas, hagan otra cosa menos ver la pantalla.
(risas)
Los que les voy a mostrar es una úlcera diabética.
Aunque, es bueno reir antes de ver esto.
Esta es la realidad de la diabetes.
Pienso que muchas veces escuchamos sobre úlcera diabética,
no conectamos la úlcera con el tratamiento eventual,
que es la amputación, si no puede curarse.
Asi pues, mostraré la imagen. No tardará mucho.
Esto es una úlcera diabética. Es trágico.
El tratamiento para esto es la amputación.
Esto es de una anciana. Tiene cáncer en el hígado así como diabetes,
y ha decidido morir con lo que quede de su cuerpo intacto.
Y esa dama decidió, después de un año de intentar tratar esa úlcera,
que deberíamos probar la nueva terapia que Steve inventó.
Así es como la herida se veía 11 semanas después.
El material contenía solamente señales naturales.
Y este material indujo al cuerpo a cambiar a una respuesta de sanación
que no tenía antes.
Voy a mostrar un par más de diapositivas perturbadoras --
les avisaré cuando puedan mirar de nuevo.
Este es un caballo. El caballo no siente dolor.
Si el caballo sufriera, no les mostraría esta imagen.
El caballo tiene otro orificio nasal
debido a un accidente de cabalgata.
Unas semanas después del tratamiento --
en este caso, se tomó el material, se hizo en gel,
y se cubrió el área, se repitió el tratamiento varias veces --
y el caballo sanó.
Si hacen un ultrasonido a esa área, se verá muy bien.
He aquí a un delfín a quien se le puso de nuevo la aleta.
Existen 400 000 pacientes en todo el mundo
que han usado ese material para curar sus heridas.
¿Se puede regenerar un miembro?
DARPA le dió a Steve 15 millones de dólares para dirigir el proyecto con 8 instituciones
para comenzar el proceso de hacer esa pregunta.
Y les mostraré la imagen de los 15 millones de dólares.
Este es un señor de 78 años que perdió la punta del dedo.
Recuerden lo que les dije de los niños que pierden la punta del dedo
Después del tratamiento, así es como luce.
Esto está pasando actualmente.
Esto es clinicamente relevante.
Hay materiales que hacen esto. Están los parches de corazón.
¿Pero se podría ir más allá?
¿Podríamos, por decir, en lugar de usar material,
tomar unas células junto con el material,
y eliminar la parte del tejido dañado,
poner un material bio-degradable?
Pueden ver aquí un pedazo de músculo cardiaco latiendo en un plato.
Esto fue hecho por Teruo Okano en el Hospital Femenino de Tokyo.
El hizo crecer tejido palpitante en un plato.
El enfría el plato, lo que cambia sus propiedades
y lo extrae directamente del plato.
Es algo genial.
Ahora les mostraré la regeneración basada en células
Y lo que les voy a mostrar aquí
son células madre removidas de la cadera de un paciente.
De nuevo, si son impresionables, no querrán mirar.
Pero ésta es muy buena.
Esta es una operación de bypass, como la que tuvo Al Gore,
con una diferencia.
En este caso, al final de la operación de bypass,
verán las células madre del paciente
que fueron removidas al inicio del procedimiento
siendo inyectadas directamente al corazón del paciente.
Y me levanto aquí debido a que en un punto
les voy a mostrar que tan novedosa esta tecnología es.
Aquí van las células madre, directo al corazón latiente del paciente.
Y si miran con cuidado,
justo esta por ocurrir
podrán ver un reflujo
Pueden ver las células regresando.
Necesitamos todo tipo de nueva tecnología, nuevos dispositivos,
para llevar las células al lugar correcto en el momento correcto.
Un poco de información.
Esta fue una prueba aleatoria.
En este momento era N de 20. Ahora es N en 100
Básicamente, si toman pacientes muy enfermos
y les hacen un bypass, mejorarán un poco.
Si se les proporcionan células madre junto con el bypass,
para estos pacientes en particular, se volvieron asintomáticos.
Ellos llevan dos años fuera.
Lo mejor sería si pudiera diagnosticarse pronto la enfermedad,
y prevenir que la enfermedad llegue a un estado avanzado
Este es el mismo procedimiento, pero minimamente invasivo,
con solo tres orificios en el cuerpo donde toman el corazón
y simplemente inyectan células madre a través de un procedimiento laparoscópico.
Ahí van las células.
No tenemos tiempo de ver los detalles,
pero, básicamente, esto también funciona.
Se pueden tomar pacientes que no estén tan enfermos,
y llevarlos a un estado casi asintomático
mediante este tipo de terapia.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo de terapia celular que aún no ha sido probado clinicamente.
Pero pienso que muy pronto lo será.
Este es el trabajo de Kacey Marra de Pittsburgh,
junto con varios colegas alrededor del mundo.
Ellos decidieron usar el fluido de liposucción,
el cual, en Estados Unidos, tenemos mucho.
(risas)
Es una gran fuente de células madre.
Las células madre estan empaquetadas en ese fluido de liposucción.
Así que pueden ir, a que les quiten algo de grasa.
Sale el fluido de la liposucción,
y en este caso, las células madre son aisladas y convertidas en neuronas.
Todo esto hecho en el laboratorio.
Pienso que muy pronto verán a pacientes que son tratados
con células madre obtenidas de su propio tejido adiposo.
Antes mencioné el uso de dispositivos
que cambiarían dramáticamente la forma de tratar las enfermedades.
He aquí un ejemplo, antes de concluir.
Esto es muy trágico.
Tenemos una colaboración permanente y conmovedora
con nuestros colegas del Instituto para Investigación Quirúrgica de la Armada de EUA,
quienes dan tratamiento a los más de 11 000 jovenes que han regresado de Iraq.
Muchos de ellos tienen quemaduras severas.
Y si algo hemos aprendido sobre las quemaduras,
es que no sabemos cómo tratarlas.
Todo lo que se ha hecho para tratar quemaduras --
básicamente hacemos una aproximación de transplante.
Hacemos algo por aquí,
y después lo transplantamos a la parte herida,
y tratamos de que ambas se unan.
En este caso, un nuevo bio-reactor que se puede usar, se ha diseñado --
y debería probarse clínicamente este año en la ISR --
por Joerg Gerlach en Pittsburh.
Este bio-reactor será puesto en la cama del herido.
La pistola que ven dispersará células.
Dispersará células por toda el área.
El reactor servirá para fertilizar el ambiente,
proporcionando otras cosas al mismo tiempo,
y por lo tanto se sembrará el terreno,
opuesto a lo que hace la aproximación de transplante.
Es una forma completamente diferente de hacerlo.
Ya casi terminan mis 18 minutos.
Permitanme terminar con unas buenas noticias,
y quizá un poco de malas noticias.
Las buenas noticias son que esto está ocurriendo actualmente.
Es un trabajo muy poderoso.
Claramente las imagenes lo muestran.
Es algo muy dificil debido a que es altamente interdisciplinario.
Casi cada campo de ingeniería científica y práctica clínica
se involucran para que esto ocurra.
Varios gobiernos y varias regiones,
se han dado cuenta de que esto es una nueva forma de tratar enfermedades.
El gobierno Japonés fue quizá el primero,
cuando decidió invertir primero 3 mil millones,
y después otros 2 mil millones en este campo.
No es coincidencia.
Japón es el país más antiguo de la Tierra en términos de edad promedio.
Ellos necesitan que esto funcione o su sistema de salud muere.
Así que invierten estrategicamente en esta área.
Lo mismo con la Unión Europea.
China, lo mismo.
China acaba de lanzar un centro nacional de ingeniería de tejidos
El presupuesto del primer año fueron 250 millones de dólares.
En Estados Unidos tenemos una aproximación diferente. Nosotros --
(risas)
-- oh, que Al Gore fuera presidente en la vida real.
Tenemos una aproximación diferente.
Y ésta ha sido simplemente patrocinar las cosas conforme vayan llegando.
Pero no hay una estrategia de inversión
para traer todo lo necesario para enfocarse y llegar a algo de manera cuidadosa.
Voy a terminar citando, quiza de manera algo injusta,
al director de NIH, quien es un hombre encantador.
Joy Vacanti de Harvard y yo
fuimos con él a visitar a varios de los directores de su instituto
hace unos meses,
para tratar de convencerlo que era momento para que tomara una parte
de esos 27.5 mil millones de dólares que va a recibir el próximo año
y los invirtiera de manera estratégica, para asegurarse de acelerar la marcha
en la que ésto llegua a los pacientes.
Al final de una reunión bastante exasperante,
lo que dijo el director de NIH es,
"Su visión es mucho más grande que nuestro apetito".
Quiero concluir diciendo que nadie va a cambiar nuestra visión,
pero juntos podemos cambiar su apetito.
Gracias.